Whoa.
Oh my God!
How crazy was that fight?
Flynn was so savage.
Have you made out
with him yet?
One, two, three…
To Ellen!
It's still Elle,
but whatever.
I'm so sorry, I forgot.
I've got some karaoke,
gotta get ready.
Guys, yo. Say hello to Elle.
Hi, Elle.
Hi!
-Hello, boys.
-Chloe! How are you?
So, who's singing
tonight then?
Oh my God!
Get dressed, naked boy.
Scandalous.
You take care of yourself.
You too.
For whatever it's worth…
I want you to know
that I think you are
an absolutely
brilliant woman.
Thank you, Chloe.
Sorry, was my description
not vivid enough?
I literally described
100 different ways
Marco can get it.
Awesome.
I take it you're the one
from the intercom?
Yeah.
But they're already
calling me
the "get-it girl",
but I go by Elle.
I don't know. "Get-it girl"
has a nice ring to it.
Cool.
Well…
goodbye, Elle Evans.
Goodbye, MVP.
Hi, guys!
-Hi!
-Hey!
That's Mrs Flynn.
She's sort of
a surrogate mom to me.
I couldn't
have made it
through the years
without her.
How's school going?
Let's just say interesting.
I don't know what
that means,
but I want to hear
all the gory details later.
Is there a problem?
Mrs Flynn?
No.
No problem at all.
I'm just not selling
this house.
You'd be walking away
from millions.
All of these old homes
are being taken down.
Just not this one.
Good day, gentlemen.
-Morning!
-Morning.
Morning.
Elle.
Dad, my pants ripped.
This is literally all I had.
I'm gonna set up
these pieces.
Good for you.
He's very particular.
Oh! And I call the race car.
Hey, Dad! Where are my
other pairs of school pants?
They're at the cleaners!
I'm not disappointed
in you, Elle.
We all make mistakes.
It's what you do after
that shows who you are.
I guess I'm next.
Whoa.
I hope you like
what you see.
Lee?
Lee!
Geronimo!
Oh, no.
Oh my God!
That was a good one!
That was a good one.
Noah.
-Hey.
-Fancy seeing you here.
-What's up?
-Nice seeing you, brother.
Good to see you, bro.
Congratulations again.
So when's the wedding?
Do you guys have a date?
Yeah, we're thinking
like late May.
Okay, late May.
Can't wait.
We were talking
about maybe going
-and getting some churros.
-Were you now?
So we'll catch up
with you guys later.
-Cool, yeah.
-Good to see you, bro.
Okay. Bye.
Lee!
You seen my athletic cup?
Yes, ass-hat!
I needed it
for all those varsity sports
I'm constantly playing,
you know?
Hey, Shelly.
He knows I hate
being called Shelly.
Yes, Noah?
I know he hates
being called Noah.
Okay, well, I mean,
when I'm in town again,
we should go
for a ride together.
Only if you'd… like that.
I would like that.
That sounds fun.
Great.
Well, I've got to go see
some friends
-and I have an early flight.
-No, of course.
But, no, no, no.
I'll call you.
Sure. Yeah.
If you've got time.
I've got time.
-I'm gonna go.
-Okay.
-All right.
I'll see…
-I'll see you later.
-Okay.
See you. Okay, bye.
Bye.
Look at that cute baby!
That's me, Elle Evans.
And the smelly, less-cute
baby right next to me,
that's my best friend Lee.
Lee and I were born on the
same day at the same time
here in Los Angeles,
California.
Our moms were BFFs
before people
even used the term BFF.
So, we were raised
like twins
and we've been pretty much
inseparable ever since.
Standing there
at the carnival
and seeing Noah again
after all that time…
I couldn't help
but think of one thing.
That all of this happened
just because of…
well, you know.